Film Courage: How did you meet Michael Jackson?
Courtney Miller,
Filmmaker/Producer/Author/Editor: How
did I meet Michael Jackson? So after all this time
of me learning his dance steps and everything I
had an opportunity to to go to an audition
and I met him on my 18th birthday actually
it wasn't at that time it was the audition was
for remember the time on my 18th birthday was
still in high school so I landed the job and
then we had rehearsals and that's when I first
met Michael was doing rehearsals from Remember
The Time and man we rehearsed on the Backlot
of Universal Studios which is really cool and
wait sorry we shot on the back lot of Universal
Studios we actually rehearsed at a studio which
is no longer around called Alley Cat off of Gower
and Sunset [Hollywood] and we rehearse there for
several weeks shot it on the back lot of Universal
Studios and yeah it was I was really happy to
be there I never thought it'd be such an iconic
music video but I mean that music video is amazing
John Singleton unfortunately passed away recently
the director who did Boys in the Hood which was a
which was a movie that I love because it was the
areas that I grew up in and it's about boys who
look like me that grew up in those kind of areas
one guy did turn into the kind of the dark side
on the other side the the other boy who were and
they were friends grew up a different way and
and then and I totally got that the ironic the
the ironic thing is that John Singleton's birthday
was also January 6. So it was like on January 6th
on my birthday got this job and John Singleton
also January 6 was was what's the director so
that was kind of cool wow yeah and when you went
there how did how did Michael come out like when
he entered the room like what was the mood in
the room like so we're in there rehearsing the
dance steps now the way we typically do this if
you're working with a large artist you typically
work with them separately so they learned
the dance steps they know them before they
come into the rehearsal the idea behind
that is that they want to come in looking
like they know what they're doing as opposed
to learning the dance steps and seeing you
you get to see all their foibles and all
their mistakes and everything like that
so by the time he came in he already knew the
dance steps at least a big chunk of them so we
were in rehearsal and then the door opens and
he comes in and we all get quiet we're like
and we're trying to rehearse still but you're
still looking on the side of your eye that's
Michael Jackson like okay and then he comes out in
the middle and the choreographer Fatima Robinson.
She introduces him we all clap for him and he's
like thank you, thank you for being here but
very quiet and then now it's just a thing now that
Michael's there we've been rehearsing we're kind
of just going through the motions but now that
Michael's here everybody pulls up everybody's like
ready like all the dance steps you hit him hardest
as hard as you can like it's now what in dance in
the Nets where we call that being full full out
dancing full out with full energy full intensity
everyone's killing it like and so Michael's
like okay like I you could tell that he sees
what this could be he gets he gets into it then
he comes in he does his steps but yeah it's like
nothing nothing beats the energy of when he's in
the room and when you are with a bunch of group
when you're with a group of dancers who know what
they're doing and are really good at what they do
it's you can feel the energy in that room and
that's how it was in every rehearsal and then
when we start shooting that's how it was and we
carried that same I mean I got a chance to work
with him when I was 18 and when I was 19 and then
for a good five-year stint went around the world
toured the world with him and everything for the
History world tour so that energy it whenever we
were around each other whenever I was with him and
other dancers that energy was was always there so
there was nothing like it when you're waiting for
him to enter he enters you're 18 and this is what
I want to do with the rest of my life or at least
for some time of it yeah did you feel like I'm
closer to it or did it feel even more intimidating
no I was never intimidated with him because again
I still had that mindset that I don't care who you
are we're all going to grow old we are all going
to get sick we're all going to die so I've never
intimidated by anyone I was just more like wow I
actually did it after all these these years from
the age of 14 13 years of age saying I was going
to do it here five years later I'm actually doing
it so it was more of more more Elation more Glee
a relief that actually after all this time
and and I have a lot of friends who became
lawyers and doctors and other things because
we were friends in junior high we didn't go to
the same high school but I have friends now
who like are very successful in that World
and I didn't go down that path because I had I had
a different mindset and to see like okay here's
the justification of all the hard work here's
the validation of all the hard work and it's
kind of nice to have that so for me once I once I
had that moment I was cool so at that point it's
game on and now it's just about it's it's this
healthy competition that dancers have between
each other we don't say anything but we know
we're trying to outdo each other and it's in a
loving way it's not in a way like okay I'm better
than you it's more like okay you do this okay
now watch this and we try to up each other and
Michael has the same kind of thing so when he's
performing he feeds off the energy that we have
as dancers going back and forth and that pulls
him up as well so there's like I said the energy
in that room is just insane and it's contagious
and and I carried that with me whenever I did
other jobs with Michael and now as a director
and so did you say I need to approach him or
no I'm going to take this slow I'm going to
let him see that I'm dedicated to this I have
discipline and and when it's when I'm ready
we'll go to the next step yeah when it comes
to Michael you don't think about approaching
them no you you you're there to do your job
and so you want to remember your job is first
it's not like I never thought well first of all
I'm 18 so I'm not thinking we're going to go out
and get any drinks or something like that I'm just
like I'm there to do a job I'm blessed to do this
job I'm blessed to be the youngest person in this
room doing this job so I'm just happy to be there
honestly at that point by the time I got to be
in my 20s that's when for me I wanted to like
I wanted to have more of a closer relationship
because we had worked so often by that point
because in 90 so it we did I remember the time
first then the very next year almost around
the same time on my birthday we worked on the
American Music Awards for a song called Dangerous
and then we did some we did a short film called
ghosts and then I toured the world with him on
the history World Tour so I've been working
with him on so many different projects and so
at that point is when I felt like I could have
a conversation with them at least hey how's it
going today how was your day those kind of
things but in the very beginning no I didn't
say anything I'm like oh okay so because I know
some people have this mindset it's but maybe it
helped that you grew up in La that they want to
just like make a beeline to a certain person and
write them a note or whatever it is and try to
jump the line so to speak and and I don't know
if that necessarily works but I know people think
that it might yeah so no and the idea of going
towards him to to communicate with him other than
to say hello I mean no I was there to do a job so
that's first and foremost and then everything else
would just happen on its own organically you would
hope so it didn't when I was on those first couple
of jobs but then later on things things started
happening where we can have more conversations
about things in life at that point I was married
I had a child so I can have I had a lot more that
I could talk about hey did you take I know this is
a strange question but did you take the bus home
that night after that that rehearsal very good
question regarding the bus so I was still busing
it through that point I think at that point I
no I probably brought my mother's car but that
job was what got me my very first car which almost
killed me that job got me a I bought my very
first car which was like a 74 Volkswagen Beetle
and I was working the following year for a
group called in Vogue I used to be a dancer
for them we were going getting ready to go on
tour and doing rehearsals I'm driving the bug
in North Hollywood off of Burbank Boulevard
and I'm driving I smell smoke I turn around
whoosh this big fireball comes from the back of
the of the car because underneath the back seat
it's stubble and it it sits right on top of the
battery so somehow the stubble in the back seat
got caught on fire probably from the battery or
the engine or the heater or something like that
which is in the back as well and so while we're
driving I'm like oh my gosh and my hair is grades
from being cinched and I jump out of the car in
the in in the street on Burbank Boulevard and
I'm rolling in the street I'd kick off my shirt I
take it off and I make sure I'm okay the carviers
hits a tree and catches this tree on fire oh
my God yeah that's my first car but I got it
oh my goodness wow
yeah it was scary of all the people you've danced
with in your life all the different names all the
unknown dancers that are probably amazing as
well where does Michael Jackson rank as far
as dance moves yeah as far as where he ranks
as far as dance moves it's really interesting
because I've got a chance to work with Usher who
copies Michael Jackson I've watched Chris Brown
who copies Michael Jackson Jason Derulo copies
Michael Jackson so I would say that Chris Brown is
probably one of the most talented dancers but he
doesn't hold a candle to Michael because Michael's
the originator you never outdo the originator so
for me as far as the dances are concerned there's
nobody like Michael like there's very few people
that that I've seen dance that can make people cry
Michael can do that I have a friend of mine who
his name is Matthew Rushing he dances he actually
is the artistic one of the artistic directors at
Avenali now he was the second person that I've
ever seen somebody dance and make people cry
in the audience like he is a beautiful dancer
and Michael was the first so unless you can do
that and move people with that kind of emotion
yeah you don't hold a candle to Michael and
when you were 18 and and in that crowd for I
remember at the time doing the dance moves was
there something in you that said you don't you
don't outdo the originator like did you want
to you're young and you you're excited and you
want to show your your stuff did you have
to remind yourself that or that came later
no I think the idea of not topping the originator
I think I'm really competitive so I don't care who
you are whether you're Michael Jackson or somebody
else I'm going to try to outdo you there's been
times when that has actually got me into trouble
like so no when I'm 18 I'm not even thinking I
like that but as I further along and get better at
my dances keep in mind I'm still in high school so
I hadn't gotten from from 10th grade to 12th grade
I was a completely different dancer I could do so
much more I could do the splits I could turn
I could jump I could leap I could do Russians
I could do a lot of I mean pretty much almost
anything I want my body to do I could probably
do by the time I was 18. The confidence was
definitely there but as I started working after
between the Michael Jackson jobs I'm doing other
jobs for other artists as well and you do more
and more work you gain more and more confidence
and so by the time we go out on tour with Michael
there's some nights when you're when you have
it when you're just killing it like dance wise
and this is one night we were in Seoul South Korea
I'll never forget this so we're performing Smooth
Criminal and we're getting ready to do the famous
lean forward it's with criminal when you watch the
music videos and also when you watch the live
shows you see this moment where Michael Jackson
and the dancers lean really far forward and then
they come back up now we do this live on stage and
to to do the trick you need to have really strong
stubbing muscles because it's all stubbing muscles
you literally tighten your body and then you lean
forward and your feet are locked in to the floor
one night I went so far no no lie my nose was
probably this far from the floor now this is from
a standing position so imagine going all the way
down down down down down down down down to your
this close from the floor and I'm next to Michael
but I'm behind Michael so if Michael's here
I'm here and you can obviously see me and I was
feeling it that night it was just a good night I
was just performing so well and I went too far and
so the show's over and Lavelle Smith who is one of
my mentors in dance he was also the dance Captain
for Michael he's been like he's been Michael from
the dangerous World Tour he's been Michael like he
was in the original Smooth Criminal he came up to
me and said hey Michael Michael asks if you can
make sure you don't leave that for him next time
interesting I said yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry so
there's going back to you what you're saying yes
there's been times when I was so hyped up I know
I never thought I was going to be better than the
originator but there's been times when like I was
just feeling it and I kind of went a little bit
too far you mentioned that you're competitive
yeah and you said sometimes it's gotten you in
trouble aside from that which it sounds like you
corrected it how has it gotten you in trouble well
now with this this new role of me being a writer
and director typically the way I have two managers
and typically the way it works when it comes to
my work as a writer is I'll write something and
I'll give it to them to look at it give me notes
on and then I'll receive it back and make some
corrections based upon the notes there's been
times when I was impatient and I wanted to get
something sold faster and so as a result I would
not send it to them I tend to write to the person
write to the executive at a studio directly
and and in those situations you have what are
called general meetings general meeting being that
those set up my managers will set up me to have a
meeting with an executive at Paramount Studios or
at bet or at Lionsgate and I'll meet this person
we have a great rapport literally it's a dual
IQ meeting do I like Courtney meeting and the
30 minutes to 45 minutes and I come in there and
they tell them a little about about my background
where I come from by then they would have seen
I have a short film which was a hip-hop musical
that I did while I was still in college that was
like my my thesis project and that project is the
is what got me the meeting so by then we've had
some discussion we they've seen some of my work
and then by the end I usually get their contact
information so I have their phone number the
email address and they're like Hey whenever you
have anything coming up in the future let me know
even though they say that the correct
route is to still go through your
managers and have your manager or
your agent send them the script
sometimes because of my competitiveness because
of my impatientness I'll just see this in the
directly and that's gotten me in trouble sometimes
so I'm still working on that from time to time
okay so advice to new writers and directors
is follow protocol yeah there's definitely a
protocol that you should be following and
and definitely follow that protocol yeah
yeah what if someone says well I'm a rule
breaker and that's how I've gotten things
done I go outside the lines yeah there are
people like myself who are sometimes will
go outside the lines and break rules but just
know that there's going to be possibly some
consequences of that and as long as you're ready
to to accept those consequences go have at it.